das kolosseum im herzen roms
[Musik]
das spektakulärste stadion der antike
erschaffen für blutrünstige schaukämpfe
eine echte legende
für die zuschauer war es das reinste
spektakel die architektur war perfekt
auf die kämpfe abgestimmt
doch was passiert wenn diese legende auf
eine moderne ikone trifft
bis heute kann das kolosseum mit
modernen arenen mit hatten die architekt
orientiert sich daran
das kolosseum
eine gigantische arena
sie zählt zu den teuersten
fußballstadien der welt
[Applaus]
wembley ist eine ikone der modernen
stadion architektur
ein wettstreit der superlative zwei
kontrahenten drei kategorien und jede
menge überraschungen
[Musik]
architektur
welches stadion hat die baukunst auf der
ganzen welt revolutioniert
erlebnis
welches stadion bietet seinen fans mehr
komfort
und
events wo finden die eindrucksvollsten
spektakel statt
[Musik]
rom schon vor 2000 jahren eine
gigantische metropole
und die hauptstadt eines reiches wie es
die welt noch nie zuvor gesehen hat
[Musik]
die römer waren dem rest der welt in
vielem überlegen in der kriegsführung
der kultur und eben auch in der
architektur
vom heutigen marokko bis zur ukraine von
der türkei bis nach schottland aus
seinem höhepunkt erstreckt sich das
römische reich über drei kontinente
und im zentrum all dessen
das kolosseum
[Musik]
das größte jemals gebaute amphitheater
der welt
156 meter breit
188 meter lang
1 48 meter hoch ist es einst das höchste
gebäude der stadt auf fünf rängen bietet
es platz für mehr als 50.000 zuschauer
ohne hightech maschinen erbaut in
weniger als zehn jahren dient es vor
allem einem zweck den römern eine show
zu bieten wie sie sie noch nie zuvor
gesehen haben
das kolosseum war mehr als doppelt so
groß wie alles was ist da vorgab das
volk hat es geliebt
doch kann die legendäre arena
tatsächlich mit einer modernen ikone
mithalten
[Musik]
london hauptstadt des vereinigten
königreichs und eine hochburg des
fußballs
hier steht ein weltweit einmaliges
stadion seit seiner eröffnung 2007 gilt
es als eine kathedrale des rasensports
lemli gehört der englischen football
association dem ältesten fußball verband
der welt hier ist der moderne fußball
entstanden
das wembley stadion ist gigantisch
ein wahrer koloss
300 meter breit
und
315 meter lang
den bogen einberechnet ist wembley fast
dreimal so hoch wie die römische legende
und genau wie das kolosseum stellt auch
einen weltrekord auf
es bietet überdachte sitzplätze für rund
90.000 fußballfans
mehr als jedes andere stadion auf der
welt
[Applaus]
schwer zu sagen welcher bau die größere
architektonische leistung ist
das kolosseum in rom und die stadion
ikone wembley messen sich in der ersten
hauptkategorie
architektur
welche arena hat die baukunst
revolutioniert
das erste was beim römischen kolosseum
auffällt es steht noch
mehrere hundert jahre haben die massen
hier die gladiatoren angefeuert die
arena hat erdbeben brände und
blitzschläge überstanden wie ist das
möglich
dass das kolosseum noch steht beweist
wie gut die römer sich auf architektur
und baustoffe verstanden einfach
unglaublich
das geheimnis der römischen baukunst
liegt in einem stoff den wir für
gewöhnlich mit dem zwanzigsten
jahrhundert in verbindung bringen beton
römischer beton hat diesen bau erst
möglich gemacht nur mit steinen hätten
sie nie diese höhe erreichen können mit
dem beton konnten sie leichter und höher
bauen
die römer entwickeln einen genialen
baustoff der im mittelalter wieder in
vergessenheit gerät die menschen der
neuzeit müssen ihn quasi neu erfinden
heute rund 2000 jahre später ist beton
der wichtigste baustoff und nach wasser
die meistgenutzte substanz der welt
viele architektonische meisterwerke des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts bestehen
aus stahl glas und beton
seine einsatzmöglichkeiten vier
unbegrenzt von wolkenkratzern über
autobahnen und tiefgaragen bis hin zum
wembley stadion
errichtet aus
23.000 tonnen stahl jeder menge glas und
vor allem mehr als
200.000 tonnen beton aber
ist der moderne beton so haltbar wie der
römische
wird wembley auf 2.000 jahre überdauern
wie das kolosseum
die meisten menschen glauben beton sei
unglaublich stabil enthalte ähnlich aber
das stimmt nicht der modernen beton hält
gar nicht so lange
die kombination aus stahl und beton
ermöglicht heutzutage zwar spektakuläre
bauwerke doch ihre lebensdauer ist
begrenzt
denn sobald der stahl rostet heißt es
weg damit
[Musik]
aber das ist nicht der einzige grund
warum das kolosseum wahrscheinlich
wembley überdauert hat
fakt ist
der römische beton trotz seit 2000
jahren hitze kälte und feuchtigkeit
dabei hat er kaum einen riss bei kunst
geschaffen für die ewigkeit
[Musik]
wir wissen dass die römer eine geheime
zutat genutzt haben etwas das wir heute
in unserem beton nicht verwenden
[Musik]
die geheim zutat entspringt einer
mächtigen naturgewalt sie kommt aus dem
inneren der erde
vulkanasche
dank ihr entstehen beim anmischen des
beton spezielle kristallstrukturen
aluminium tober moritz dieses mineral
macht den römischen beton extrem
beständig
benannt wurde die zutat die sogenannten
put solana nach der stadt porto goalie
150 kilometer südlich von rom hier liegt
jena supervulkan der die wertvolle asche
liefert
er ist bekannt als die pflegerischen
felder und fliegt in der nähe des vesuvs
[Musik]
die natur ist voller wunder vulkane
können zu einer bedrohung seien für die
langlebigkeit antike bauwerke waren sie
jedoch ein segen
selbst wasser eigentlich schleichendes
gift für beton kann dem römischen super
material nichts anhaben kopf bei
aquädukte
abwasserkanälen oder hafenanlagen
die porzellane machen rom buchstäblich
zur ewigen stadt
das kolosseum zeugt bis heute von
brillanter baukunst aber auch von
grausamen spektakel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und von der größe römischer kaiser
[Applaus]
wembley dagegen ist ein bauwerk der
schnelllebigen gegenwart
schwer vorzustellen dass es länger als
100 jahre stehen wird
spätestens dann werden die massen in
einen noch beeindruckenderen sporttempel
strömen um ihre lieblingsmannschaft auf
dem spielfeld zu sehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wembley ist so eine moderne ikone doch
seine lebensdauer ist begrenzt
fazit der römische beton hat die
architektur revolutioniert wird seine
haltbarkeit ist er dem heutigen der auch
beim wembley stadion verwendet wurde
weit voraus
doch wer weiß vielleicht wird der
nachfolger des wembley-stadions genau so
lange stehen wie das kolosseum
ist die römer damals gemacht haben ist
keine technik von gestern in zeiten des
klimawandels könnte so die zukunft
aussehen
moderner beton ist ein energiefresser
und klimakiller
knapp drei milliarden tonnen co2
entstehen bei seiner herstellung jedes
jahr
fast dreimal so viel wie durch den
weltweiten flugverkehr
bei der römischen variante fällt weniger
co2 an er ist also nicht nur langlebiger
sondern auch klimafreundlicher
runde zwei in der kategorie architektur
das kolosseum zählt zu den
eindrucksvollsten bauprojekten der
antike
kann sein design mit dem einer modernen
super-arena mithalten
die ersten steinernen amphitheater roms
entstehen im ersten jahrhundert nach
christus
den auftrag für das kolosseum erteilt
kaiser vespasian es soll das
spektakulärste von 1 werden alle
arenen im römischen reich haben eine
ovale grundform
doch keine erreicht auch nur annähernd
die ausmaße des kolosseums es bietet
über 50.000 sitzplätze
mehr als jedes andere amphitheater
seinerzeit
messer für die menschen wie ein wunder
so ein großes gebäude zu sehen
das größte gebäude im antiken rom
erschaffen für aufwendig inszenierte
kampf events die gladiatoren spiele
werden zu einem beliebten
freizeitvergnügen der römer der andrang
ist riesig
doch wie ist es den römern gelungen ein
so gigantisches bauwerk auf die beine zu
stellen das geheimnis ist eine
bahnbrechende errungenschaft
der rundbogen
240 stück hat das kolosseum im außenring
nach innen setzten sich die rundbögen zu
gewölbe gängen fort
das gesamte gebäude ist im grunde eine
aneinanderreihung von rundbögen ohne sie
würde das kolosseum unter seinem eigenen
gewicht zusammenbrechen
denn die baumaterialien der antike wie
stein oder beton halten kaum
zugbelastung aus dem rundbogen wird der
druck des gewichts nach außen in die
säulen geleitet
auszug belastung wird so druckbelastung
das zentrale element ist der zuletzt
eingesetzte schlussstein am scheitel
jedes bogens er trägt selbst kein
gewicht sondern verteilt die last und
hält die anderen steine in position
indien im prinzip basiert die römische
baukunst auf dieser genialen umwandlung
von zug und druckbelastung
es ist die vielleicht größte
architektonische leistung der römer der
rundbogen ist perfekt um ein großes
gewicht zu tragen
dank ihm können sie lange aquädukte und
brücken bauen
und
imposante gebäude wie das pantheon
indem sie den bogen weiter entwickeln
zur kuppel
[Musik]
eine erfindung die in den folgenden 2000
jahren so allgegenwärtig sein soll dass
sie uns kaum noch auffällt rundbögen
finden sich überall
von washington dc in den usa bis ins
russische moskau
ab dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert werden
stadien jedoch auf andere weise gebaut
wie etwa das michigan state im mittleren
westen der usa
das kolosseum ist nun nicht mehr die
größte sportstätte auch die zeit der
rundbögen ist vorbei
jüngste oder stahlskelett hat es
ermöglicht erstmals größere stadien zu
bauen dan stahl hat mehr zugbelastung
aus das ist viel effizienter so und
bögen
dennoch lebt die idee des bogens in
wembley weiter wenn auch auf ganz andere
weise das designelement das als erstes
auffällt der dachboden
mit einem umfang von einem kilometer
bietet wembley wettergeschützte
sitzplätze für 90.000 zuschauer
anders als beim kolosseum ist dank des
stahlskelett baus die zentrale
herausforderung nicht die größe sondern
eine bogenförmige dachkonstruktion
es gibt ja heute so einige stadien in
ähnlicher größenordnung anders als beim
kolosseum damals
die herausforderung ist also etwas
anderes zu finden dass ein stadion
unverwechselbar macht
und das gilt natürlich umso mehr für
wembley mit seiner besonderen
vorgeschichte
das alte wembley stadion mit seinen
legendären zwillingstürmen spätestens
als england hier zum ersten und einzigen
mal die fußball- weltmeisterschaft
gewinnt ist klar das herz der englischen
fußballfans wird für immer an diesem
stadion hängen nach seinem abriss muss
ein design her dass alles bisher
dagewesene in den schatten stellt
der gigantische bogen das wahrzeichen
des neuen stadions stellt die erbauer
vor einmalige herausforderungen
21 meter lange 100 tonnen schwere teile
müssen auf der baustelle montiert werden
fünf computergesteuerte litzen heber
ziehen den bogen zentimeter für
zentimeter in position er soll das neue
wembley stadion zur ikone machen und das
gigantische dach tragen
so etwas hatte bis dahin noch niemand
gebaut der bogen muss über stahlseile
nicht nur das enorme gewicht des dachs
halten sondern auch sein eigenes gewicht
von
1750 tonnen freien der luft stehen
der bogen das dach und insgesamt sechs
kilometer stahlseil wilden ein komplexes
system
das gewicht des dachs setzt die kabel
unter spannung und stärkt damit den
bogen
der wiederum kann so dass 7000 tonnen
schwere dach tragen
der clou der konstruktion das dach
besteht aus einer reihe von sheva
paneelen und ist beweglich
der bogen ist nun teil der größten
einzel dachkonstruktion der welt er
macht das wembley stadion zu einem
kilometer weit sichtbaren symbole zu
einer unverwechselbaren ikone der
gegenwart
beide bogen konstruktionen sind
architektonische geniestreiche jede auf
ihre eigene weise ob wembley architektur
auch in die geschichte eingeht wird sich
noch zeigen
die dritte und letzte runde in der
kategorie architektur
die bauzeit
[Musik]
eines vorweg den römern gelingt etwas
woran heute viele bauprojekte scheitern
und das größte gebäude im antiken rom zu
errichten braucht es mehrere
hunderttausend tonnen material und
zehntausende arbeiter für einen
reibungslosen ablauf auf der mega
baustelle sorgt eine methode die als
errungenschaft des industriezeitalters
gilt die massenproduktion
dank sich wiederholender formen und
bauteile können die arbeiter effizient
und eigenständig vorgehen
an standardisierung und massenproduktion
diese prinzipien wurden im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert als neue errungenschaften
gesehen aber tatsächlich hatten die
römer vor 2000 jahren schon danach
gearbeitet
dank dieser methoden können die erbauer
des kolosseums eine riesige heerschar an
ungelernten arbeitern einsetzen allein
in den steinbrüchen bei tivoli sind
tausende im einsatz das römische reich
braucht viele sklaven für seine
bauprojekte und die holt es sich auf
brutale weise
im jahr 70 nach christus kurz bevor der
bau des kolosseums beginnt schlagen die
römer einen aufstand in judäa lieder und
erobern jerusalem sie verschleppen
30.000 kriegsgefangenen
aus dem jerusalemer tempel erbeuten sie
zudem wertvolle schätze bevor sie ihn
zerstören
jede menge geld ziehen tausende sklaven
massenproduktion und ein ausgeklügelter
bauplan
so errichten die römer das kolosseum in
weniger als zehn jahren
für die zeit und die verfügbaren mittel
war das unglaublich gut
heute hingegen gibt es kaum ein
großprojekt bei dem nicht sowohl die
bauzeit als auch die kosten explodieren
das opernhaus in sydney die bauarbeiten
dauerten zehn jahre länger als geplant
die elbphilharmonie in deutschland mehr
als zehnmal so teuer wie veranschlagt
und der berliner flughafen neun jahre
später eröffnet als angekündigt bildet
wembley da eine ausnahme
nein der ursprüngliche plan ist wembley
in drei jahren hochzuziehen doch dann
gibt es probleme verzögerungen und eine
kostenexplosion sind die folge woran
liegt das wie beim kolosseum besteht das
stadion zwar weitgehend aus
standardisierten bauteilen aber die
komplexe dachkonstruktion ist mit dieser
methode nicht realisierbar
außerdem verändert sich noch in der
bauphase das design anfangs ist eine
aschebahn für leichtathletikwettkämpfe
geplant doch die wird mittendrin
gestrichen
im nachhinein schoben sich alle parteien
gegenseitig die schuld für die probleme
in die schuhe es schien eine ganze liste
an gründen zu geben
dazu gehören auch designfehler und
lieferengpässe mit den verzögerungen
explodieren die kosten auf insgesamt
1,2 milliarden euro
deutlich mehr als veranschlagt war
bis heute gehört wembley zu den
teuersten stadien der welt
die ersten testspiele finden ein jahr
später statt als geplant
[Musik]
mit einer bauzeit von knapp vier jahren
ist wembley zwar mehr als doppelt so
schnell wie das colosseum entstanden
allerdings lief das ganze auch
chaotischer und teurer ab
das fazit in der kategorie architektur
das kolosseum setzt zu seiner zeit
maßstäbe die römer sind begeistert
wembley dagegen muss so manche väter
lassen
[Musik]
zeit für die zweite kategorie
das zuschauer erlebnis
welches stadion beschert seinen
besuchern ein erlebnis der superlative
dazu gehört zunächst die massen
möglichst sicher und reibungslos zu
ihren plätzen zu leiten die alten römer
waren meister darin
massenveranstaltungen zu organisieren
die lenkung der 50.000 besuchern
kolosseum ist legendär das kolosseum hat
80 nummerierte eingänge auf jede
eintrittskarte steht welchen eingang der
zuschauer benutzen soll über vier
umlaufende korridore und zahlreiche
treppen gelangt er auf direktem weg zum
sitzplatz
insgesamt führen 80 öffnungen sogenannte
vitória zu deutsch in etwa ergießen ins
innere des zuschauerbereich er ist in
fünf ränge unterteilt so findet jeder
mühelos und in kürzester zeit seinen
sitzplatz
[Musik]
dieses system die massen zu lenken war
wirklich großartig es prägt bis heute
die modernen stadien
wie wichtig die effiziente lenkung der
zuschauerströme ist zeigt sich besonders
wenn alle gleichzeitig hinauswollen
historiker schätzen dass sich das
kolosseum in gerade einmal 15 minuten
räumen ließ
die durchdachten leitsysteme
sicherheitskräfte und die tatsache dass
im kolosseum vorwiegend sitzplätze gibt
machen den besuch dort sehr sicher
[Applaus]
moderne fußballstadien dagegen haben
sich nicht immer als so gefahrlos
erwiesen
[Musik]
die stadien des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
mit ihren großen stehplatz blöcken und
ungenügenden fluchtwegen haben sich als
ziemlich gefährlich herausgestellt dass
hesl stadion in brüssel
1985 dringen anhänger des fc liverpool
in einem mit juventus turin fans
besetzten block 1 die geraten in panik
und versuchen zu fliehen
39 menschen kommen ums leben mehr als
450 werden verletzt
vier jahre später drängen zu viele
anhänger des fc liverpool ins büro
stadion in sheffield seine am
spielfeldrand und zwischen den blöcken
verhindern dass die menschen der enge
entfliehen können
96 menschen werden in der menge erdrückt
[Musik]
auch deshalb gibt es im wembley stadion
keine zäune und keinen einzigen
stehplatz wer hier rein will für den
heißt es hinsetzen das bedeutet 90.000
zuschauer teilweise rivalisierende fans
müssen sicher zu ihrem sitzplatz genutzt
werden eine riesige herausforderung
wie im kolosseum sind auch hier
zahlreiche sicherheitskräfte damit
beschäftigt die massen unter kontrolle
zu halten
[Musik]
dabei haben sie technische unterstützung
mit hilfe von überwachungskameras
kontrollieren sie das geschehen vor und
im stadion
doch wie schnell kommen die fans rein
und wieder raus
[Musik]
system aus vielen nummerierten eingängen
treppen und korridoren eine dem im
kolosseum
das wembley stadion hat insgesamt 14
eingänge auf zwei ebenen
das innere des stadions ist unterteilt
in 148 blöcke jeweils mit eigenem zugang
im notfall dauert es nur zwölf minuten
bis alle besucher ins freie gelangen
beeindruckend wenn man bedenkt dass in
wembley fast doppelt so viele personen
platz finden wie im kolosseum
fazit die moderne ikone gilt als
außerordentlich sicher auch weil sie die
zuschauer auf ähnlich intelligente weise
durch das stadion lässt wie schon die
römer vor 2000 jahren
der nächste vergleich wo haben die
zuschauer einen besseren blick auf die
arena
primetime im kolosseum die gladiatoren
treten an und die besucher wollen vor
allem eines mit eigenen augen miterleben
wer siegt im kampf um leben und tod
die sicht hängt von der entfernung zur
arena ab und davon ob sie durch
hindernisse wie dachstützen versperrt
wird
das dach des kolosseums ein riesiges
sonnensegel
aufgespannt von bis zu 1000 männern und
an 240 aus masten fixiert mit einem netz
ausbauen
das bedeutet freie sicht für alle die
zuschauer könnten kaum näher am
geschehen sein die tribüne grenzt direkt
an die arena
die sitzreihen folgen dicht an dicht
sie sind gerade einmal 73 cm tief
dazu kommt die steigung
je abschüssiger die anordnung der
tribünen desto geringer ist die gefahr
dass der vordermann die sicht versperrt
und desto näher ist man an der arena mit
37 grad neigung sind die tribünen
ähnlich steil wie in den meisten
modernen stadien die maximale entfernung
zur arena liegt bei 55 metern
[Musik]
beeindruckend und dazu kommt dass die
tickets kostenlos waren aber natürlich
konnte nicht die da sitzen wo er wollte
das hing vom sozialen status ab
die schlechtesten plätze sind auf dem
oberen rang sie sind für frauen der
untersten schicht und sklaven vorgesehen
die beste sicht genießen die senatoren
der adel und der klerus
dabei geht es nicht nur darum die kämpfe
zu sehen sondern auch den kaiser
hier kann er sich seinem versammelten
volk zeigen
[Applaus]
selbst die zuschauer auf den
schlechtesten plätzen haben noch eine
gute sicht
das liegt auch an der form des
amphitheaters
die ist in vielen modernen stadien
nahezu identisch ob im park de france in
paris dem
aztekenstadion in mexiko city
dem first national bank stadium in
johannesburg oder
auch im wembley stadion
alle haben die gleiche ovale grundform
mit ringsherum ansteigenden zuschauer
ringen was die römer vor 2000 jahren
entwickelt haben hat bis heute bestand
beliebt bei der ägyptischen form ist die
sicht deutlich besser als bei einer
runden oder eckigen form weil es zum
beispiel keine toten winkel gibt bis
heute orientieren sich architekten da an
den alten römern
wie damals grenzen auch beim wembley
stadion die besten plätze direkt ans
spielfeld
doch können sogar die fans auf der
obersten tribüne fouls und fehlpässe mit
bloßem auge sehen
wembley hat hier einen entscheidenden
nachteil seine größe die entfernung zum
spielfeld beträgt auf den schlechtesten
plätzen 83 meter
[Musik]
zwar ist die neigung ähnlich steil wie
in rom und nah an der grenze bevor den
besuchern schwindlig wird
aber durch die 80 zentimeter tiefen
sitzreihen steigt mit jedem rang auch
die distanz zum rasen
[Musik]
mehr komfort dafür größere entfernung
immerhin hat kein einziger sitzplatz
eine beeinträchtigte sicht denn das dach
kommt trotz seiner enormen größe
komplett ohne stützen aus
das ermöglicht die raffinierte
bogenkonstruktion die einen großteil der
last trägt
zudem soll technik die größere
entfernung wettmachen
dank zweier videoleinwände jede so groß
wie 600 fernseher entgeht einem auch auf
den billigen plätzen nichts
apropos billig welchen platz ein
besucher ergattert hängt anders als im
antiken rom ausschließlich vom
ticketpreis ab den er zahlt
fazit und entschieden gemessen an der
größe sind die sichtverhältnisse im
wembley-stadion phänomenal ebenso wie
die im kolosseum
aber ein stadion lebt nicht allein vom
blick aufs spielfeld
mindestens genauso wichtig ist der
perfekte sound
der lärm im kolosseum ohrenbetäubend
durch die dicht gepackten ränge und die
mitreißende kampf show kommen die fans
so richtig in fahrt die atmosphäre
definitiv vergleichbar mit den stehplatz
kurven in heutigen stadien
die akustik im kolosseum trägt
wesentlich zu dieser hexenkessel
stimmung bei
den architekten des kolosseums war klar
dass form steigung und material
ausschlaggebend für die stimmung und die
akustik sind
der geschlossene ovale bau erzeugt viele
echos und verstärkt den jubel der massen
durch die nach oben hin zu nehmende
steigung entsteht quasi eine parabolica
schüssel das sonnensegel trägt ebenfalls
dazu bei die publikums hofe
zurückzuwerfen
hartes material wie der verwendete stein
sorgt zusätzlich für stärkere echos und
damit für eine höhere lautstärke
und in der regel gilt je lauter desto
emotionaler
[Musik]
bei der qualität der akustik kann die
legende jedoch weniger punkten
in wembley dagegen sind die
ausgangsbedingungen etwas komplizierter
hier finden vielfältige events statt die
alle eine andere akustik brauchen
außerdem soll das stadion jedem
zuschauer maximalen komfort bieten
die großzügige beinfreiheit sorgt für
mehr distanz zwischen den zuschauern
stimmung und lautstärke leiden darunter
und reichen nur schweren die des alten
stadions heran
das alte wembley stadion war weltberühmt
für seine einzigartige akustik den
sogenannten wembley war der grund dafür
große flächen wie das dach ließen den
schall abprallen und haben ihn so
verstärkt tonaufnahmen zweier
finalspiele im alten stadion werden zum
benchmark für die architekten des
nachfolgers
sie bauen den untersten rang mit mehr
reihen um so den geräuschpegel auf dem
feld zu erhöhen eine glaswand zwischen
der obersten sitzreihe und dem dach
verhindert dass der schall entweicht
gleichzeitig will man vermeiden dass
echo hotspots entstehen weitere
glasflächen etwa bei den vip boxen sind
deshalb versetzt angeordnet sie brechen
den schall auf und lenken das echo
ausschließlich auf den bereich direkt
vor der box
dieser trick soll die akustik bei musik
events verbessern denn in wembley finden
nicht nur fußballspiele statt sondern
auch konzerte zu viele echos wären da
ein problem
[Musik]
indem sie glasflächen im winkel von fünf
grad versetzt zueinander angeordnet
haben wollten die wembley designer
verhindern dass manche plätze echos aus
allen richtungen abbekommen
die inspirationsquelle tarnkappen
flugzeuge genau wie deren verwinkelte
oberflächen radarwellen den
unterschiedliche richtungen reflektieren
passiert es im stadion mit dem schall
das ergebnis kann sich hören lassen
aber auch die römer vor 2000 jahren
wussten wie man einen bombastischen
sound erzeugt
deshalb lautet das fazit in der zweiten
kategorie in puncto besucher erlebnis
kann es die antike legende mit der
modernen ikone aufnehmen
kommen wir zu kategorie 3
wo finden die eindrucksvollsten events
statt im kolosseum erwartet die besucher
ein blutrünstiges programm die massen
sind regelrecht süchtig danach
das highlight aufwendig inszenierte sie
schlachten diese sogenannten no marien
sind nicht nur spektakulär anzusehen
sie erfordern auch einen kolossalen
aufwand
dafür muss die komplette arena geflutet
werden um einen wasserspiegel von
eineinhalb metern zu erreichen sind fast
vier millionen liter wasser nötig
[Musik]
bis zu 15 meter lange extra flache boote
fahren ein an bord die gladiatoren
verkleidet als soldaten stellen sie
ruhmreiche seeschlachten nach und treten
gegeneinander an
ein spieltag dauert damals keine 90
minuten wie beim fußball sondern von den
morgenstunden bis zum abend der tag
beginnt mit der ersten kampf gattung
mensch gegen tier exotischen kreaturen
aus aller welt sollen demonstrieren wie
weit das imperium des kaisers reicht der
nächste makabre programmpunkt volk zur
mittagszeit hinrichtungen und
schließlich am abend das highlight die
gladiatorenkämpfe entscheidend für den
reibungslosen ablauf das labyrinth aus
gängen unterhalb der arena
im untergeschoss gab es ein komplexes
system aus räumen aufzügen und
versorgungsschächte mit denen tiere
bühnenbilder oder gladiatoren wie von
geisterhand in die arena befördert
wurden
bis heute ist dieses bühnensystem nicht
vollständig erforscht
die unterirdischen konstruktionen sind
nicht erhalten geblieben
die holz ist verrottet doch aus den
rillen aussparungen und löchern im stein
lässt sich ableiten dass die tiere
damals mit lasten auf zügen aus dem
untergeschoss in die arena gebracht
werden
[Musik]
das unterhaltungsprogramm war wahnsinnig
aufwendig für das publikum wurden keine
kosten gescheut nicht zuletzt dank
dieser technischen innovationen ist das
kolosseum legendär
überlieferungen zufolge finden im ersten
jahr zur einweihung 100 spieltage in
folge statt immer vor vollem haus ganz
anders in wembley hier gibt es gerade
einmal um die dreißig
großveranstaltungen im jahr mit
insgesamt rund zwei millionen besuchern
es ist vor allem fußball der die
menschen in die arena lockt schließlich
ist wembley-stadion der englischen
nationalmannschaft
seit der eröffnung 2007 gab es außerdem
zahlreiche musik events
hinzu kommen boxkämpfe rugby und
football spiele
eine große bandbreite die modernste
technik erfordert
die videowände haben eine gesamtfläche
von
195 quadratmetern
[Musik]
knapp 400 led flutlichter beleuchten das
spielfeld
der bogen erstrahlt dank
228 led lampen in millionen verschiedene
farbkombinationen
[Musik]
die technische ausstattung ist state of
the art
doch dem stadion fehlt es an etwas
anderem
legendären ereignissen die in die
geschichte eingehen
[Musik]
das kolosseum und das at wembley stadion
sind legendär aber beim neuen stadion
warten die fans bis heute darauf dass
sie etwas stattfindet was die welt nie
vergisst
wie zum beispiel live aid eines der
größten konzerte der rockgeschichte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
abgehalten im alten wembley-stadion
fazit dem neuen wembley stadion fehlt es
trotz modernster technik noch an
magischen momenten das kolosseum dagegen
hat mit seinen gigantischen
wasserschlachten längst geschichte
geschrieben doch wie steht es um die
vielleicht wichtigste zutat für eine
massen euphorie stars
immer wieder werden gladiatoren im alten
rom zu stars durch wiederholte siege und
aufsehenerregende kämpfe steigen sie auf
und gewinnen die gunst des volkes
[Applaus]
der glanz der von erfolgreichen
gladiatoren ausgeht ist so groß dass
sich überlieferungen zufolge selbst
kaiser wie commodus in die arena begeben
[Applaus]
gladiatoren waren die sport stars der
antike
ihnen wurden preise verliehen und
denkmäler gesetzt die frauen schwärmten
für sie
viele gladiatoren sind als
kriegsgefangene oder sklaven nach rom
gekommen die kämpfe sind ihre einzige
chance freiheit zu erlangen reich oder
gar berühmt zu werden ihre ausbildung
ist knallhart und hochprofessionell ein
tunnel verbindet das kolosseum mit der
größten der vier gladiatoren schulen
roms dem ludus magnus ihre arena ist gut
60 meter lang und 40 meter breit
[Musik]
die kämpfer leben in angrenzenden zellen
die alltag ist streng geregelt sie
werden sorgfältig ernährt massiert und
einem intensiven training unterzogen
die arena ist umgeben von acht
sitzreihen und bietet platz für 3000
zuschauer ein beliebter zeitvertreib für
viele römer
in der regel treten gladiatoren mit
unterschiedlicher ausrüstung
gegeneinander an deren vor und nachteile
sich gegenseitig aufwiegen
am beliebtesten ist der rätia rios ein
leicht bewaffnete kämpfer mit dreizack
und netz
die verschiedenen arten von gladiatoren
haben sogar eigene fan gruppen
manche bitten geld auf ihre helden
andere halten gladiatoren blut für ein
heilmittel gegen so manche krankheit
[Musik]
das kolosseum es hat gefangenen zu stars
gemacht
[Musik]
im gegensatz zur emblem hier werden
keine stars gemacht wer hier auftritt
ist schon einer
wenn die fußballer in der arena stehen
kämpfen sie nicht um ihr leben sondern
um einen pokal
[Musik]
und noch etwas unterscheidet die spieler
von den gladiatoren
keiner kämpft für sich allein
[Musik]
anders als bei den kandidaturen ist im
fußball doch in erster linie die
mannschaft und nicht der einzelne
spieler der star
im wembley stadion finden die endspiele
der englischen premier league statt die
siegerelf erklimmt die 107 stufen bis
zur royal box um von mitgliedern des
britischen königshauses den heiß
begehrten pokal zu empfangen eine
tradition die es schon im alten
wembley-stadion gab
in diesen räumen bereiten sich die
profis auf die matches vor
die kabinen wurden seit der eröffnung in
futuristischem design komplett neu
gestaltet
[Musik]
erwartet werden die spieler von den
vielleicht enthusiastischen fans der
welt
[Applaus]
england ist wahrscheinlich das
fußballverrückte land der welt fans
heißen ja auch supporters also
unterstützer und genau so verstehen sie
ihre rolle in dem aktiv am spiel teil
trotz ticketpreisen von umgerechnet 45
bis zu mehreren hundert euro hat wembley
einer auslastung von 78 prozent
fazit eine große arena braucht
persönlichkeiten die sie füllen und die
gibt es heute genauso wie vor 2000
jahren mit dem unterschied dass sie im
antiken rom nicht immer leben davonkommt
doch wie steht es um das leibliche wohl
der zuschauer sind sie im kolosseum
ähnlich gut versorgt wie in einem
modernen stadion
historiker vermuten dass die senatoren
im alten rom von sklaven bedient werden
das einfache volk hingegen kauf bei
händlern in den gängen
[Musik]
snacks und essig wasser verkauft dazu
gab es um die 100 trinkbrunnen für die
zuschauer am hohen personen wurde wein
auf serviert
und was wenn die besucher die
erfrischungen wieder loswerden wollen
das kolosseum verfügt schon damals so
wie viele öffentliche gebäude roms über
ein abwassersystem
unterhalb der arena verlaufen vier
kanäle die das abwasser sammeln und der
hauptleitung zu führen
wo die latrinen für die besucher waren
ist unklar vermutungen zufolge gab es
für die normalen zuschauer eine rinne im
dritten rang und für die senatoren und
geistlichen mama bänke
im vergleich zu heute mutet die
versorgung jedoch spartanisch an
das wembley stadion bietet seinen
besuchern deutlich mehr komfort und kann
sogar mit einigen superlativen aufwarten
in älteren stadien oft ein ärgernis die
halbzeitpause reicht kaum aus um sich
mit einem bier oder snack einzudecken
ganz anders in wembley wenig später
sagen wembley ist ein einkaufszentrum
mit einem fußballplatz
das stadion trumpft mit
688 imbissständen und sechs restaurants
auf in 98 küchen wird das essen
zubereitet während einer halbzeitpause
können bis zu 40.000 getränke über die
theke gehen
wer hot dogs und fischen chips
verschmäht der findet in wembley zwei
der größten edelrestaurants londons
und schlangen vor den wcs sind hier
geschichte dafür sorgen
2618 toiletten
damit hat wembley in dieser runde
eindeutig die nase vorn
von essig wasser und toiletten mangel
wie im kolosseum keine spur
das fazit in der dritten und letzten
kategorie die events im kolosseum haben
eingang in die geschichtsbücher gefunden
wembley dagegen fehlt es an magischen
momenten dafür sind die zuschauer dort
gut versorgt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fast 2000 jahre liegen zwischen dem
hightech stadion wembley
[Musik]
und dem kolosseum in rom
ob design baumaterial oder
besuchermanagement
vieles in der antiken arena wirkt noch
heute verblüffend zeitgemäß
[Musik]
[Applaus]